could this be the closest thing to an
actual flying car asca's hybrid vertical
takeoff and Landing A5 car made a splash
when they debuted their production
Prototype at this year's CES see as well
as being an aircraft ask his A5 is also
designed to drive on roads meaning you
could fly from door to door using just
one vehicle that's the plan anyway but
right now it's not quite there yet
so as always we're going to look at
where asker is now where it wants to be
in the future and what it needs to do to
get there but let's start with where it
wants to be the idea behind desk is A5
is pretty simple instead of commuting to
an airport boarding an aircraft
disembarking and commuting to your final
destination asker believes that with
their A5 you can do the entire
door-to-door journey in just one vehicle
their four passenger SUV sized aircraft
car air car is designed to drive on
roads and uses in-wheel electric motors
when you're ready to fly asker says the
vehicle will unfold its wings and take
off with a range of 250 miles and an
operating cost of one dollar per mile
thanks to its hybrid electric gasoline
engine but what's more interesting than
the stats around the A5 is how ASCA
envisages it being used in the future
because as well as selling to private
buyers and I will get to that ASCA told
me they also believe that the A5 could
fundamentally change how we commute if
it were to be used as an air taxi asker
says that because the A5 can fly and
drive you won't need to build
infrastructure around Landing sites as
you won't need to provide parking
waiting rooms terminals or charging you
just need somewhere with enough room to
spread your wings and they say that
means that Landing sites could be pretty
much anywhere the company told me that
in the future this used gas stations
could be perfect as distributed Landing
sites though that obviously relies on a
future where we no longer need gas
stations and nobody else has snapped up
that real estate
but all that's in the future so where is
the company now well it's important to
note that this thing hasn't actually
flown yet the company is awaiting
experimental certification from the FAA
and is aiming to get production
certification by 2026 though it is
currently able to drive on roads but
while they await that production
certification you are able to reserve
your own A5 for personal use the final
cost 789
000 that puts it in roughly the same
price range as a Robinson helicopter
though obviously helicopters vary wildly
in price the company tells me they've
received around 100 pre-orders so will
ask as A5 really be able to create a new
affordable way for the average person to
commute well the key question here is
whether it can actually save passengers
time and money see while asker says the
A5 will take you directs from door to
door it will still need to go via a
suitable takeoff spot and in dense Urban
centers it's likely air traffic managers
will have a say over where those spots
can be after you've driven to your
takeoff spot slightly you'll want to
make sure your batteries are fully
charged before you fly and that takes
time and even when you land you might
not be able to use the fastest roads to
get to your final destination as the A5
isn't yet certified to drive on highways
that could mean that the overall journey
is no faster than getting a train or
taxi to and from a fully charged or
fueled aircraft but I guess it does cut
out the inconvenience of having to
transfer and then there's cost while the
company says that ride hailing trips
could be as cheap as an Uber black at
789 thousand dollars that's quite an
expensive vehicle even for Uber black
standards though the company told me
they hope to get the cost down to 200 to
300 000 per vehicle as they ramp up
production unless asker can prove that
they can save passengers time and money
it's going to be challenging for their
ride hailing business to compete with
other air taxis let alone conventional
multimodal transport
so for askers A5 to truly change how we
commute the company will need to receive
certification on a production model and
certification to drive on highways sell
some initial vehicles to the public
reduce production costs and then somehow
prove that flying and driving in just
one vehicle can be dramatically more
efficient and cost effective than
multimodal transport until all that
happens it's unlikely that you'll see
askers A5 flying as an air taxi but you
might still see a few flying around our
skies in the next few years just being
flown privately
[Music]